[Música]
bienvenidos a ello soy de france 24 las
mujeres están rompiendo con los roles de
género en chile en un camino contra la
discriminación se eleva la construcción
de un edificio hospitalario con mano de
obra enteramente femenina la gobernación
de marga marga lanzó en 2020 un programa
de formación en carpintería enfierradura
y albañilería más de 36 mujeres s
certificar así que con miras a realizar
el proyecto se decidió que las secciones
de sala cuna sería una tarea femenina
una iniciativa inédita y ejemplo para
las industrias
mujeres albañiles topógrafos o maestras
de obra hormigoneras y carpinteros
trabajan mano a mano por un legado que
disfrutará la población de valparaíso de
la que sería la guardería del hospital
marga marga en la provincia que lleva el
mismo nombre es la protagonista de la
historia
nuestra corresponsal patricia luna pasó
una jornada en el lugar
a primera vista la construcción del
hospital marga marga no tiene mucho de
especial pero en este área todo cambia
aquí están los cimientos del primer
edificio que será construido sólo por
mujeres en todo el país
alexia la más joven de las trabajadoras
no oculta su orgullo ante los progresos
de estas 35 mujeres que trabajan como
peones de albañil y que antes de llegar
aquí no contaban con experiencia previa
no me siento orgullosa porque si nos
damos cuenta hemos logrado
bastante 2 de marzo entonces es como el
orgullo de hacer algo verlo terminado y
es como emocionante y bueno
hace 21 años ya pasó antes por una obra
en construcción para hacer la limpieza y
seguro que nunca volvería por el acoso
que sufrió pero volvió para hacer la
carpintería moldajes y hormigón hería de
éste a la vez que sigue sus estudios de
diseño industrial a sus 40 años claudia
decidió salir de la comodidad de su
hogar y ponerse el mundo por montera y
el casco de albañil con esfuerzo llegó a
ser maestro de obra e inició estudios de
construcción tuvo que vencer barreras
mentales y muchos muchos prejuicios
cuando yo llegué acá lo dijeron ustedes
no van a poder
los compañeros como fui la primera no
van a poder se rieron de mí en mi cara
cuando dijeron pagas de la sala cuna
esto no va a quedar bueno y es
demostrarle que sí que avanzamos que
está quedando bueno
en total entre obreros y profesionales
56 mujeres forman parte de esta obra
destinada a cambiar la historia de la
construcción en chile de manera
excepcional la verdad o sea se está
cumpliendo la planificación que ellas
mismas realizaron se está trabajando con
una calidad en la ejecución de los
trabajos exquisitas y sobre todo y lo
más importante es con un ambiente
laboral
excepcional las mujeres llegaron para
quedarse aportando compañerismo y su
perfeccionismo al sector de la
construcción
para conversar sobre esta historia nos
acompaña en ella soy tatiana hernández
ella es socióloga e integrante del
directorio de la ong observatorio de
género y equidad
tatiana bienvenida gracias por estar con
nosotros y comenzamos de una vez la
crisis sanitaria ha mostrado terribles
violaciones a los derechos de las
mujeres pero también esa voluntad de oro
para traer sustento al hogar sin
importar la tarea cuando en medio de la
pandemia la provincia de marga marga
lanzó esta iniciativa para formar a
ciudadanos en construcción la gran
sorpresa fue una amplia aspiración de
las mujeres tenemos que sentirnos
realmente sorprendidas o más bien
preocupadas porque históricamente no
hemos dado el espacio para que nos
desarrollemos libremente en el plano
laboral
a ver las mujeres tienen sin duda tienen
la aspiración que me imagino yo tienen
todas las personas de poder acceder a
estos derechos como el derecho a
trabajar en igualdad a que los hombres
sin embargo como como ustedes bien ponen
en en el reportaje lamentablemente la
institucionalidad
a la altura de las circunstancias y
fundamentalmente el propósito de la
pandemia que estamos viviendo y de la
crisis que implican las medidas de
confinamiento que yo no las cuestionó
todo lo contrario si significa salvar
vidas pero donde ha afectado
fundamentalmente la participación
laboral de las mujeres a propósito de
cómo se agudiza la división sexual del
trabajo entonces
hoy día las mujeres estén diciendo que a
pesar de de lo que estamos viviendo a
pesar de la regresión en la división
sexual del trabajo están dispuestas a
trabajar pero lamentablemente a
propósito de responsabilidad familiar es
a propósito de la suspensión de
condiciones que habíamos logrado las
mujeres en chile detener como por
ejemplo sea la cuna no universal pero
que existe el tema de la educación
pública de que los niños puedan ir que
si bien es cierto no es no es como
garantía de cuidados pero es parte del
tiempo que las mujeres pueden usar
también trabajando cuando los niños
están en el colegio creo que tú toda esa
regresión ha implicado que muchas
mujeres salieron del mercado del trabajo
y volver ha sido un tema muy complejo
cuando llego muy complejo es que la
mayoría está en response está
cuando uno hace la encuesta mira la
encuesta nacional de empleo en chile y
ve por qué las mujeres han disminuido su
empleabilidad tiene que ver con el
asunto de la responsabilidad familiar
entonces ver esto ver que además ahí hay
un sector empresarial que apuesta en las
mujeres apuesta además entendiendo que
históricamente hace un sector altamente
masculinizado me parece interesante sí
creo que hay temas que la misma el mismo
reportaje usted dan cuenta de que hay
que abordar y que tiene que ver con
estos dispositivos de control que tienen
estos sectores altamente masculinizados
e indicarle las mujeres seguir
indicándole a las mujeres que ese lugar
no es el de ellas que ellas siguen
siendo intrusa en ese espacio y que
tiene que ver con con estas con estos
mensajes no como ustedes no van a poder
que las mujeres no son buenas parece
para hacer ese tipo de trabajo y otros
temas que seguramente no lo abordan
reportaje porque no lo comentan las
mujeres seguramente pero tiene que ver
con el acoso sexual que ocurre
fuertemente en eso espacio altamente
masculinizado yo creo que las empresas
de estos sectores tienen que ir
generando mayores condiciones no
solamente materiales que si no que
también simbólica para que las mujeres
podamos ingresar mayoritariamente ahí
pero también desarrollarnos y
mantenernos en estos espacios mira
tatiana justamente quería preguntarle
por ese tema por la expectativa ahora en
el caso de marga marga porque será ver
la calidad de la construcción hay
muchísimo en juego con este ejemplo y
este ímpetu que están poniendo estas
mujeres en el tema laboral pero entonces
va a ser complicado desde los juicios de
los compañeros hombres de estas
constructoras hasta la visión que van a
tener los usuarios de valparaíso y ahí
yo le pregunto rápidamente será más dura
la evaluación precisamente por ser
mujeres las constructoras
probablemente desde desde el lugar de
los compañeros de trabajo si yo no sé
desde el lugar de los usuarios de las
usuarias yo creo que los usuarios les
gustaría fundamentalmente las usuarias
seguramente van a tener una respuesta
mucho más favorable y a propósito de las
diferentes sistematización e
investigaciones que se ha hecho en torno
a la construcción y tienen que ver
y aquí favorablemente juega o sea juega
favorablemente la socialización de
género que las mujeres terminan mucho
mejor las construcciones que los hombres
las terminaciones son mucho mejores
acabadas
a propósito de que nos educaron a ser
minuciosa en lo que hacemos no que en la
misma motricidad fina que tenemos que no
la tienen los los varones a propósito
insisto de una socialización donde nos
enseñan a tejer nos enseñan a coser nos
enseñan a usar las manos de una manera
muy distinta así que tampoco es justo
porque los hombres también deberían
tener esa posibilidad de desarrollar
esas habilidades
absolutamente por eso te digo que en
este caso la socialización de género tan
desigual juega a favor de las mujeres y
que muchas constructoras de esto están
formando y así generando esta alianza
entre estado empresa de ir formando
mujeres mujeres que que puedan ir
haciendo las terminaciones más
minuciosas en la construcción pero esto
es estos ustedes hoy día están
visibilizando va mucho más allá porque
da cuenta no solamente de terminar toda
una construcción sino quiere comenzar la
y terminando entonces
[Música]
tengo la impresión además que aquí hay
muchas cosas en juego entonces digo a
propósito de que son sólo mujeres
entonces seguramente la el componente
más técnico de cómo se hizo sin duda va
a significar de que está de que esta
construcción sea de alta calidad no me
cae ni una duda y además de que muchas
de estas mujeres en marga marga vienen
desde la vulnerabilidad mujeres cabeza
de hogar mujeres separadas mujeres
sobrevivientes de violencia sexual y
esto simplemente nos muestra porque van
a tener trabajo hasta 2024 con esta
construcción pues que a través del
trabajo se dignifica y también se
superan los traumas y las dificultades
que tenemos solamente por haber nacido
nacido mujeres
sin duda un asunto fundamental la
propósito de las autonomías para las
mujeres es contar con recursos y poder
decidir sobre qué hacemos con esos
recursos no con esa con lo que ganamos a
propósito del empleo remunerado y en ese
sentido nos permite tomar decisiones de
romper con dinámicas de violencia romper
con con condiciones materiales de
pobreza
y generar nuevas redes redes en torno a
compañeras en torno a lo mismo al mismo
trabajo creo que es tremendamente
relevante que mujeres como usted bien
dice con estas condiciones de
vulnerabilidad porque no es que las
mujeres seamos vulnerables sino que hay
un sistema económico cultural social y
político que lamentablemente no va a ser
así
mire esto ya para cerrar el tiempo
porque se nos acaba el programa es en
conclusión un trabajo de mujeres para
mujeres y al final una mujer trabaja
para todo el mundo por un lado de la
sala cuna pues va a ser el lugar en el
que los empleados van a poder dejar a
sus hijos y poder acudir a cumplir sus
obligaciones y por otro lado este
hospital está ubicado para nuestros
televidentes en villa alemana y gran
parte de la comunidad tenía que
trasladarse a esta viña del mar para
procedimientos como incluso tener hijos
ahora van a poder tener a sus hijos en
su propia localidad y pues esto
significa muchísimas gracias a ustedes
por estar con nosotros y a nuestros
televidentes sigan en france24
[Música]